Okay, welcome to the very first module above the line, below the line thinking.
Now this is a simple powerful model to help you know how you're doing when it
comes to pressure, comes to different stresses in your life. It's very very
simple but it's going to help you know how you're tracking and what to do about
it. Now before we get into this model let me tell you a little story about how
powerful the simple model is. Many years ago I was traveling to Nepal and I
went into a remote village and I met a school teacher called Jabaraaj and I
stayed in this little village about seven hours on a bus from Kathmandu and I
stayed up there for a while and taught Jabaraaj this model and he taught it to
all the children in school and then we made a big post and we put it up in the
school. Now it was a great time and I left back to the country I was living in at the time.
Some time passed and the massive earthquake took place in Nepal, devastated
Jabaraaj's village. He lost his home, most of the people lost their homes in his
little village up in the mountains. The school was badly damaged and it was
devastation and I checked in on Facebook you know how are you Jabaraaj? Because he
actually had Facebook and reception all the way up there in the mountains and it
was going through a difficult period, he didn't speak much and anyway some time
passed and I flew back to visit Jabaraaj in Nepal and when I first saw him he
looked at me and he had so much emotion in his face and he hugged me and he cried
and he told me how learning this above-the-line model that you're about
to learn how he believed it saved his life and he said that he, Jabaraaj, was
above the line and his wife was below the line and you're gonna learn what this
means in a minute and how he really was strong as a leader, helped his village
come through this very very difficult period of their lives and such a simple
little model helped him have the awareness because everything begins with
awareness, helped him have the awareness to be able to to be the type of leader
for his family and for his village to go through a very difficult time. So
this is really exciting to bring you this model. Now in the next video you're
about to watch it's an animation that we put together for athletes. I used to
work with a lot of young athletes and high-level professional athletes so we
put this together and so there's gonna be some sporting words or terminology
that you can watch but this is gonna teach you the model and then when you
come back from that animation I'll join you once again and we're gonna go into
it in a bit more depth and discuss that in more detail. So enjoy and I'll see you
when you come back.